bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo nous
sommes à strasbourg au parlement
européen
dans cette émission je vous emmène en
allemagne depuis quelques mois de
nombreux réfugiés syriens sont
accueillis en famille dans des centres
on leur apprend à lire par les comptes
et en allemand objectif les réinstaller
durablement loin de la guerre et des
camps de réfugiés
mais d'abord l'actualité avant d'évoquer
l'épineux dossier de l'immigration la
guerre est déclarée entre martin schulz
et les députés du front national le
président du parlement européen a saisi
l'olaf l'office de répression des
fraudes
motif des assistants parlementaires
seraient payés par le parlement mais
pour ne pas y travailler
et la réponse de marion maréchal-le pen
ne s'est pas fait attendre et monsieur
schulz qui tint est un militant
politique parce que lors des européennes
il avait fait un certain nombre de
meetings contre le front national est
bien à appliquer à la lettre les ordres
de monsieur valls qui hier expliqué
qu'il fallait que les élites se
mobilisent contre front national
j'attends donc maintenant les directeurs
de publication les banquiers et autres
copains élite de monsieur valls pour
s'acharner contre nous parce que c'est
de l'acharnement politique évidemment en
pleine période électorale
et pour évoquer ces questions c'est eva
joly que je reçois bonjour bonjour on
est ravi de vous recevoir un joli vous
êtes députée européenne membre du groupe
des verts est bien entendu ancienne
candidate à l'élection présidentielle en
france
quand vous entendez marion maréchal-le
pen parler d'acharnement est ce que vous
êtes d'accord
le front national m à se poser en
victime et il voudrait échapper aux
magouilles qui sont faites parce que la
réalité c'est qu'ils font fonctionner le
parti leur parti le front national avec
les fonds européens l'aube alors que
l'évidence les fonds européens ne sont
pas fait pour ta retourner le front
national
oui mais c'est pas la première fois eva
joly et on le sait bien ici au sein de
ce parlement que des assistants
parlementaires sont également élus ou
dans l'organigramme de leur parti s'est
passé pas nouveau
là c'est très massif et l'adresse et le
front national
le travail fait c'est c'est le front
national
ils ne travaillent même pas pour les
députés qui les a nommé assistant donc
c'est vraiment une magouille et on voit
bien que le front national lorsqu'il
prend les pauvres dans les communes
comme hayange par exemple avec mesurant
gelman c'était une gestion autoritaire
et magouilleurs donc pour ceux qui sont
si hostile à l'union européenne
on voit bien que c'est aussi eux qui
profitent le plus des ces fonds dernière
question et on passera un autre sujet
quand on voit que ça se fait en plus en
pleine période électorale puisque les
départementales vont se tenir dans une
dizaine de jours en france
est-ce que c'était le moment est ce que
ça va pas un plus apporté de l'eau au
moulin du front national vous savez il
ya des règles et ces règles s'appliquent
dans les communes au front national et
au parlement européen au front national
et voudrait bien c'est un extrait il ya
des règles pour les s'appliquer c'est
tout simple bon eh bien écoutez comme
vous le savez certainement après des
mois des terres d'atermoiements la
commission européenne s'est décidée à
prendre à bras le corps la question de
l'immigration
alors peut-on réguler c'est la question
qu'on s'est posée cette semaine
c'est une priorité de la nouvelle
commission européenne et de son
président jean claude juncker
l'immigration ce dossier épineux conso
jette comme une patate chaude de conseil
européen conseil européen d'une
commission à l'autre depuis des années
et là enfin début mars une annonce
les travaux de la commission européenne
sur un programme européen global en
matière de migration ont débuté
aujourd'hui
waouh on ne s'y attendait pas il faut
dire que depuis les révolutions arabes
et la chute de ben ali et kadhafi les
frontières extérieures de l'europe sont
poreuses
combien de bateaux et de corps échoués
sur les plages de l'île italienne de
lampedusa
combien de réfugiés noyé dans le fleuve
evros à la frontière gréco turque
des milliers des dizaines de milliers
dans un rapport l'agencé frontex estime
que le nombre de réfugiés entrés
illégalement dans l'union européenne a
été multiplié par 3 en 2014 syrie irak
erythrée soudan du sud il faut dire que
les guerres aux portes de l'union sont
légion et les trafiquants profitent
alors peut-on vraiment réguler
l'immigration clandestine
eva joly vous y croyez à cette annonce
de la commission européenne enfin un
plan sur l'immigration c'est un thème
récurrent c'est le chaos du monde c'est
les guerres cd guerre en syrie au mali à
un soudan du sud
seger et le chaos qui met les actrices
uma ils fuient leur pression ils fuient
les guerres et oui ce sont des urgences
humanitaires bien voir que l'europe en
est un accueil très peu est ce que vous
savez que le liban a accueilli un quart
de sa population flic près de deux
millions d'habitants supplémentaires
effectivement à la règle a aussi la
turquie sont deux cent mille syrien dans
les camps et vous savez combien ont pris
les français de syriens l'année dernière
500 et l'allemagne on a pris beaucoup
plus ils ont pris dix mille la fed en a
pris trente mille donc on voit qu'il ya
des pays plus généreux qui d'autre mais
l'idée que nous puissions avoir l'europe
forteresse qui n'est pas concernée par
notre propre politique étrangère et par
les catastrophes qui s'abat sur les
populations étaient évidemment une
illusion d'accord est-ce que vous avez
des très populiste que de vendre aux
électeurs que va là nous allons fermer
les frontières l'europe on va interdire
l'accès parce que c'est ce que vous
attendez en fait de la réponse de la
commission vous pensez que c'est ça
qu'ils vont sortir rires et puis depuis
quinze ans et la politique européenne
c'est de faire l'europe forteresse c'est
d'interdire l'accès aux migrants et on
parle aussi d'immigration choisie
c'est-à-dire qu'on
on mettrait en place un bureau où on
irait chercher finalement les élites
entre guillemets chez ces réfugiés
est ce que ce serait pas une solution vu
qu' il y a des besoins pour certains
pays je pense notamment à l'allemagne
côté c'est terriblement cyniques c'est
la carte bleue c'est la politique qui
est en place depuis 2009 qui voudraient
drainait le cerveau du mali du sénégal
du maroc de tous les pays vers l'union
européenne c'est à dire 'nous' à
sécheron les pays en voie de
développement de leur cerveau et nous ne
participons pas aux régler leurs
problèmes et manifs alors ça veut dire
qu'on accueille tout le monde eva joly
savez nous les frontières et on
accueille tout le monde ça veut dire que
nous devons savoir des voies d'accès à
l'union légale kenese où les migrants
n'expose pas leur vie aujourd'hui la
politique de l'europe forteresse est
inefficace parce que et on voit l'
agence frontex talât ont annulé des
chiffres on les voir on ne marche pas et
nous mettons en péril la vie des
migrants prêts dont nous avons ya brami
le mans - des filles
oui on méditera début des années 2000 on
fait quoi donc on monte des bureaux dans
ces pays en guerre pour proposer le
droit d'asile c'est quoi comment vous
voilà marche je pense qu'il nous il faut
des voies d'immigration illégale il faut
qu' il y ait un flux autorisée wen qui
correspond peut-être à ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui comme migrants illégaux
parce qu'il y a un besoin l'allemagne a
besoin de migrants donc il ya un besoin
en europe et il faut que ça soit par
devoir légal et pas simplement pour les
eaux via graphiques et des bêtes au foot
et voilà et sa maîtresse à couperait
l'herbe sous les pieds des trafiquants
parce qu'aujourd'hui le business les
plus rentables au monde
c'est le trafic d'êtres humains là le
problème c'est que on voit bien que vous
vous plantez la question des bateaux
fantômes
quelle marge de manoeuvre on a pour
lutter contre ces trafics finalement
mais nous avons des conventions
internationales nous avons l'obligation
de ces courir
les personnes qui risquent leur vie et
nous voyons bien que l'europe
aujourd'hui ils n'appliquent pas ces
conventions et le peuple libanais
deviendra un cimetière pâques nous l'a
bien réglée il a pris la parole comme un
vrai homme d'état et on l'aimé et animés
par le désir de soulager la souffrance
donc l'europe doit prendre sa part ce
qu'elle ne fait pas aujourd'hui
dernière question on voit bien que le
problème de ces guerres en fait été au
coeur de cette problématique
on intervient en irak en syrie au yémen
pour couper l'herbe sous le pied des de
ces trafiquants et de ses et de ses
poches de violence qui pousse les gens à
partir de chez eux
on essaye intervenir uniquement par voie
aérienne dans le nord de l'irak de la
suffisance et c'est très limité comme
ouvrir les bras bien on va bien que
jusqu'à maintenant nous n'avons pas
réussi à contenir liesse et nous voyons
aussi en libye un état failli qui est
ouvert en naviguant et aux extrémistes
donc on intervient militairement avec
des sharks est ce qu on va bien qu'elle
aura en appelant l'armée
donc vous êtes d'accord pour faire une
armée européenne à l'image de
jean-claude juncker ça c'est aussi une
idée qui n'est pas nouvelle elle est là
depuis des années 50 c'est comme le
dossier de l'immigration
oui c'est un long chemin mais c'est un
objectif pour moi c'est d'avoir une
armée européenne mais il faut gérer tout
ça il faut d'abord devenir un état
fédéral nous avoir avoir des structures
fédérales parce qu'aujourd'hui qui
commanderait cette armée sourire
est ce que le parlement c'est par
travaillant parallèlement à l'événement
contrôle et l'exécutif ici trop morcelé
donc c'est un objectif à plus long terme
un objectif important pour avoir une
politique étrangère européenne
bah écoute et merci beaucoup et eva joly
on restera là dessus sur cette question
mais nous on continue sur cette question
des réfugiés parce que justement nous
nous sommes rendus en allemagne donc un
pays qui accueille de nombreuses
familles de réfugiés syriens leur offre
la possibilité d'apprendre l'allemand et
de se réinstaller un programme qui pour
l'instant ne fait pas l'unanimité en
europe vous le disiez la france en a
accueilli à peine 500 nous nous sommes
donc rendus dans la banlieue de
düsseldorf c'est un reportage de jérôme
bonnard
et tu es mal et shaya bana bana bana et
syrienne elle a 8 ans il y a quelques
jours elle vivait encore au liban avec
ses petits camarades dans des camps de
réfugiés
beaucoup sont nés pendant la guerre il
découvre pour la première fois les joies
de l'école au programme un apprentissage
intensif et sur mesure de la langue de
goethe
car désormais leur terre d'accueil c'est
l'allemagne
en fait on évite de parler avec les
enfants de ce qu'ils ont vécu là bas on
ne parle que de choses positives
ils apprennent vite grâce à une méthode
lui dire qu est positive les enfants
jouent chantent dessinent ils apprennent
toujours en jouant avec nous on essaie
de leur faire vivre une journée de
classe normale
ces petits réfugiés et leurs familles
sont arrivés mi février
il reste deux semaines dans ce centre
d'hébergement comme eux ils sont chaque
mois une centaine à venir du liban ils
font partie d'un programme humanitaire
contrairement aux demandeurs d'asile ils
obtiennent dès leur arrivée un permis de
séjour de deux ans car l'onu tire la
sonnette d'alarmé les camps aux
frontières syriennes sont saturés 3,8
millions de syriens ont fui la guerre
près d'un million et demi vivent au
liban alors lagence demande aux pays
riches et notamment à l'europe de faire
un effort pour aider ces réfugiés et là
quelle heure
cette heure bien
grâce à dieu je me sens très bien je
suis en sécurité
je remercie tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à
venir du jour au lendemain je me suis
vraiment senti à l'aise dès l'arrivée
les familles sont prises en charge
cours de langue informations générales
sur la vie en allemagne
de quoi préparer la nouvelle vie qui les
attend le centre de frais de l'inde est
située à une centaine de kilomètres au
sud de hanovre ici transit des réfugiés
du monde entier savamment garçon tu as
bien travaillé
content gaia doit signer nayem et leurs
parents sont syrien ils ont été
sélectionnés par l'onu grâce aux
programmes humanitaires allemands
pour eux c'est une délivrance au liban
c'est simple on n'avait pas d'avenir
et si on était resté en syrie cela
aurait été encore pire
regardez mon petit garçon il n'a jamais
vu l'école jamais eu de libre il a
appris un peu d'anglais et un peu
d'arabe
mais c'est tout et mon grand là il a
commencé l'école en syrie mais il a déjà
tout oublié
ça fait des années qu'ils n'étaient pas
retourner en classe
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas imaginer
rentrer en syrie un jour on aura
sûrement le mal du pays
mais pour l'instant notre vie est ici
la famille baala partira bientôt
s'installer dans la région de dusseldorf
les parents pourront travailler depuis
2013 vingt mille réfugiés syriens font
partie de ces programmes d'admission
temporaire
l'allemagne a fourni près de 400
millions d'euros dans l'aide humanitaire
pour répondre à la crise syrienne
loin devant les autres pays d'europe la
france a promis seulement 1000 places
d'ici fin 2015
l'allemagne qui voit sa population
vieillir se distingue en europe par sa
générosité
mais jusqu'où le peut-elle ya bien sûr
évidemment des limites cv on ne compte
pas accueillir quand même des centaines
milliers de demandeurs d'asile
ici sur notre sol en allemagne ou
dossier tenir compte de ces programmes
d'admission temporaire des programmes
qui prévoit d'ailleurs près de 20000
places sinon il y aura des problèmes de
logistique ne serait ce que pour les
loger et pour les intégrer dans la
société
le pays accueille déjà avec la suède
près de la moitié des demandes d'asile
de syriens en europe en dehors des
programmes humanitaires
aujourd'hui il demande aux autres
membres de faire des efforts on a vu les
images des réfugiés naufragés de van
lente et 12 ha et les gens disent bien
sûr qu'il faut faire quelque chose alors
on peut le faire il faut le faire
pourquoi on ne fait pas ou lhimer là
l'argent
demande d'asile programme d'admission
temporaire au total quelque 80000
syriens sont entrés en allemagne depuis
le début de la guerre selon l'onu trois
cent quatre-vingt mille réfugiés
identifié comme vulnérable nécessite
d'être accueillis à eux aussi par les
pays riches et voilà donc pour ce
reportage tourné à hanovre par jérôme
bonnard je reçois pour en parler cécile
klainguer députés italienne socialistes
et démocrates bonjour merci d'être avec
nous regrette l'ancien ministre de
l'intégration parfaitement voilà et
philippe juvin vous êtes porte parole de
la délégation ump française au sein de
ce parlement bonjour merci d'être avec
nous je me tourne vers vous cécile kenya
est ce que ces programmes de
réinstallation sont une solution pour
les réfugiés syriens
alors je crois que il faut distinguer
deux choses
d'un côté le fait qu' il ya une solution
qui est un brief terme c'est à dire on
doit de toute façon donné une solution
pour ne pas laisser mourir
toutes ces personnes et de l'autre côté
faire un programme à long terme c'est à
dire un programme est effectivement qui
doit être un programme holistique en
prenant en considération tous les
aspects effectivement du fait que les
personnes sont en train de fuir la syrie
ce qui veut dire les accueillir aussi en
europe
soyons clairs là dessus c'est que vous
êtes prêt vous audio sein du groupe
socialiste ou vous même personnellement
à vous dire on ouvre les frontières et
on permet aussi au liban d'être
déchargés on en accueille plus que vingt
mille en allemagne plus que mille en
france
bah il faut il faut essayer de voir que
20000 la place de toute façon à côté de
3 millions huit cents personnes il ya
quand même une belle différence donc le
fait de pouvoir demander aux pays riches
de pouvoir faire quelque chose et vous
voyez vous même qu'il ya une grande
différence donc entre 3 millions et 800
personnes et 36 mille places qui ont été
des places qui ont été réservées pour
l'europe et je crois que l'allemagne
jusqu'à présent c'est le pays qui a avec
la suède et en allemagne et suède
et ce sont les pays qui ont fait quand
même des grands efforts pour essayer de
donner une solution concrète
donc c'est pas une invasion comme tel
mais ces questions de m concrètement ce
que ce qui fait partie de notre
constitution qui est la solidarité et
notre groupe socialiste à dire à sa
fille
partie de nos valeurs mais je crois que
c'est pas seulement de notre groupe mais
ces contenus dans la constitution
européenne c'est à dire solidarité et
aussi le partage équitable des
responsabilités alors c'est la deuxième
partie aussi qui manque le partage
équitable des responsabilités et ben
justement fait début juin est-ce qu'on
ne partagerait pas assez ses
responsabilités eu égard à ce qui se
passe à quelques kilomètres entre
guillemets de nos frontières
tant qu'il y aura des guerres est encore
à des conflits il y aura évidemment des
demandeurs d'asile et l'europe joue son
rôle en accueillant et en protégeant en
même temps quand j'entends dans le
reportage que la france serait un
mauvais élève
moi je ne peux pas à laisser dire ça
reste présente et non mais par des
doigts mais la france est généreuse et
si on perd même de milo la suède 30
milles et la france 1000 c'est vrai que
ya un décalage
la seule petite différence la seule
petite différence c'est que ce jugement
doit être un jugement global et la
france est un pays accueillant est un
pays généreux en matière d'immigration
on ne règle en eux on n'analyse pas la
question d'immigration uniquement sur le
focus spécial à l'ayroule savez bien sûr
mais là on parle de la question des
réfugiés syriens fidèlement donc c'est
pour ça que je vous réponds plus
globalement en matière de générosité
d'accueil et de protection je vais pas
me soigner dans ce défi je pense que la
france est généreuse alors je vais vous
parler de manière spécifique de la
question des réfugiés syriens parce que
c'est ça qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
quand on voit que le liban a désormais
un tiers de sa population quasi
supplémentaire qui est composé de
réfugiés dans des camps de réfugiés
est-ce que les 1000 places qu'offre la
france aujourd'hui c'est pas un petit
peu ridicule premièrement c'est un
problème complexe qui ne peut pas se
régler
d'un point de vue national la réponse ne
peut être que paneuropéenne revermont
deuxièmement vous ne pouvez pas faire
abstraction de la question de
l'immigration
globalement et en particulier de
l'immigration illégale en disant ne
traite que la question syrienne la
question elle est globale et
troisièmement je pense que ces
programmes sont indispensables mais ils
sont loin madame le ministre l'a dit de
régler la question
la vraie question c'est comment fait on
pour que des populations qui sont en
danger chez elles ne soient plus en
danger de chez elle c'est ça la vraie
question qui se pose alors justement
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans ce cas là on
intervient militairement cécile king est
pas nécessairement c'est à dire
en ce moment moi je crois que il ya
aussi une question qu'on doit se poser
puisque la série est en train de passer
ces moments difficiles de conflit mais
il ya très peu d'actions pour aider les
populations et aussi pour aider la fin
du conflit
donc il faut qu'on s'interroge sur tout
ça le rôle des nations unies et le rôle
de la communauté internationale bon il
ya des points sur lequel je suis
d'accord avec lui puisque c'est pas une
question qui doit être analysé de façon
sectorielle c'est une question qui doit
être analysée d'une façon internationale
global c'est pourquoi j'ai dit dans la
première question il faut une approche
holistique
alors ils empêchent religieux belle
exactement une approche holistique de
l'immigration c'est à dire en dôme est
là dedans la question des réfugiés ou
d'omettre là dedans ne voit l'égard des
générations exactement de mettre
là-dedans
la possibilité exactement de pouvoir
faire des récettes elle-même
c'est-à-dire aussi dans les pays dit à
la causerie l'association installations
dont les pays
la collaboration avec les pays tiers
mais il ya aussi le fait qu'on doit
aussi lutter contre le trafic des êtres
humains et je crois que si on n'arrive
pas à affronter d'une façon on distingue
tous ces problèmes et je pense qu'on
entendra toujours au rang c'est
simplement un exemple pour vous montrer
que l'argument qui consiste à dire
regardez l'allemagne et la suède sur les
onze élèves et nous serions les mauvais
élèves
évidemment je m'inscris en faux contre
cette analyse l'april à l'aide médicale
aux populations en situation régulière
sur nous sur nos territoires
évidemment quand vous êtes malades en
france on vous soigne en italie c'est
pareil mais en suède pour vous faire
soigner quand vous êtes en illégal ça ne
marche pas quand vous allez dans un
service d'urgences en suède alors qu'on
demande 20 euros un suédois
on demande 200 euros un illégal en
france et en italie c'est quelque chose
d'inimaginable donc moi je veux bien
qu'on vienne nous donner des leçons mais
je dis à nos amis allemands et suédois
l' approche doit être globale et je dois
pouvoir vous juger d'une manière globale
et je trouve que encore une fois nos
pays méditerranéens ont leur part
d'effort qui est largement importante
parce que derrière vous avez des
questions d'emploi de logement
d'intégration d'éducation de sécurité
regard décalé donc on voit bien que ces
jugements un peu à l'emporte-pièce sont
fous alors je
revenir sur ce que vous disiez alain st
cécile king et sur le fait qu'il faut
réfléchir de manière globale à ses
questions sur la question des réfugiés
de l'immigration illégale
vous connaissez bien le problème de
l'île italienne de lampedusa et de ces
filières qui permettent en fait à des
réfugiés ou à des immigrés clandestins
de venir dans des bateaux fantômes là
depuis quelques mois
est-ce que vous pensez que la solidarité
européenne en fête a été a été complète
sur cette question c'est que il y a eu
pas mal de polémiques là dessus est ce
que vous pensez que la question est
réglée
non elle n'est pas réglée complètement
et je crois que peut-être de l'europe
s'y tromper en en faisant terminer le
programme marino sont c'est à dire je
venais on est dans cet îlot n'est ni
certains la recherche sauver un
immigrant mais aussi c'était lutter
contre le trafic des êtres humains
alors j'aimerais tout justement rappeler
puisque moi j'étais au gouvernement
qu'on l'a fait ce programme
c'était le lendemain de la tragédie de
lampedusa mais mordeur exactement donc
il fallait trouver une solution à tout
ça ne pouvait pas laisser les personnes
à mourir dans la mer méditerranée
il fallait qu'on donne une réponse en ce
moment si ce qu'on peut faire c'est de
protéger les migrants dans les pays de
transit s'est essayé de ne pas le faire
prendre des bateaux pour traverser la
mer méditerranée mais on ne peut pas
laisser la mer méditerranée devenir un
cimetière que me le disait exactement en
passant de marc heno sumatriptan il y à
moi je crois que l'europe a fait un pas
en arrière puisque en ce moment là
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il n'y a pas
eu la solidarité mise en action mais il
ya eu la spontanéité c'est à dire on
laisse à chaque pays de pouvoir décider
si collaborer et bien non mais la
solidarité doit être entre 28 pays
oui pas seulement les pays du sud de
l'europe exactement premièrement le
le gouvernement socialiste de matteo
renzi a exercé les fonctions de
présidence de l'union européenne
pendant six mois il s'était fixé comme
objectif majeur cette question de
l'immigration illégale
venant d'afrique il a échoué puisque la
situation aujourd'hui est probablement
pire qu'elle ne l'était avant
deuxièmement je pense qu'il est
fondamental qu'on est des populations
sur place mais pas seulement en matière
de sécurité en matière de santé et
d'éducation
quant à lui qu'au développement du co
développement tant que vous aurez temps
quand votre enfant est malade et que
vous voyez que de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée on peut le sauver alors
chez vous on ne peut pas le sauver et
bien vous fait le voyage est donc de
toute façon cette question est
fondamentale tant qu'on n'aura pas réglé
il y aura de l'immigration illégale qui
nous pose un problème majeur réellement
et enfin troisième point
je pense qu'il est intéressant de noter
que quand il ya 100 demandes d'asile
politique en france il ya 85 qui sont
refusé au motif qu'il n'y a pas de
danger pour la personne qui fait cette
demande dans son pays d'origine
donc en fait il n'y a que 15 % c'est ce
que dit le juge en france des demandes
d'asile qui sont justifiées donc on voit
bien que la question n'est pas que la
mise en danger la de l'état de danger
pour la population qui qui migrent mais
la vraie question halles est aussi et
avant tout économique
nous sommes nous sommes vu de ces pays
en difficulté un asile de richesse qui
fait qu'il ya une attraction
moi j'aimerais reprendre certains
certains thèmes d'un côté puisque mon
collègue a dit au gouvernement matteo
renzi a échoué alors il faudrait bien
précisé non mais le problème c'est pas
là et c'est justement là que je voudrais
rappeler c'est pas le gouvernement
matteo renzi qui a échoué mais c'est
l'europe ce sont les états membres
puisque c'est pourquoi j'ai dit tant
qu'on ne mettra pas
tous le problème c'est que c'est un
dossier qu'on se refile sur la tête
chaussé sa priorité
oui mais c'est pas la responsabilité du
gouvernement c'est la responsabilité des
états membres
et ce sont les états membres puisque
matteo renzi avec le gouvernement samedi
- gouvernement a quand même proposé le
le programme traitance était pour la
première fois les états membres se sont
mis ensemble pour essayer quand même
concrètement d'affronter ce thème
bon l'étape successives n'a pas été
accompli c'est à dire le fait que
concrètement ils doivent aussi partager
les ressources il doit s'engager les
responsabilités mais il faut dire que le
premier pas a été fait c'est la première
fois que les états membres se sont mis
ensemble pour essayer d'affronter ce
thème il ya notre point que j'aimerais a
souligné le fait que mon collègue a dit
que bon il ya un effet attractif des
pays du sud est où je crois que si une
personne est très bien chez soi nous
avertir et oui on n'a pas besoin de
prendre un bateau là aussi que les
risques sont développés au développement
des pays du sud parce que tant qu'on
aura un abîme de développement forcément
vous vous aurez intérêt vous et votre
famille donc la question il faut donc
j'aimerais insister sur sa puisque le
rôle par exemple de la haute
représentante de la mangue erin et avec
la nouvelle approche qu'on doit avoir
dans la stratégie de l'immigration c'est
le fait qu'on doit avoir une forte
politique étrangère donc il ya aussi le
rôle de la coopération internationale
on va terminer là dessus je voudrais
quand même signalé philippe juvin que
vous venez de sortir un ouvrage qui
s'appelle notre histoire les 100 dates
qui ont fait la nation européenne chez
lattès très rapidement quelques mots
pourquoi cet ouvrage c'est un ouvrage
sans livres d'histoire comme les 100
dates pendant lesquelles il ya eu la
prise de conscience de ulysse à la chute
du mur de berlin d'une conscience
européenne je pense que pour faire de
bons européens on a d'abord besoin
d'avoir conscience de ce qu'on a fait
ensemble dans le passé
bon bah écoutez on lira j'espère au sein
de téléspectateurs merci à tous c'est la
fin de cette émission vous retrouverez
kathia gilder la semaine prochaine à
bruxelles ciao